we've been going through the years of
Seth's life so in your 20s you also met
your wife Lauren so how'd you all meet
uh we met um through a friend at a
birthday party actually
um and uh yeah we started dating on our
very first date we got a terrible car
crash actually someone hit our the car
we were in
um I was driving and it was bonding it
was like we survived a little uh action
movie together yeah
um like a bad one oh dude my car was
completely trashed yeah we were on the
freeway and a 16 year old who had taken
his uh dad's car clipped the back of my
car and we spun out across the entire
freeway and uh wound up facing the
opposite direction uh we were going like
60 miles an hour uh it was it was insane
we're lucky to have survived
um and so yeah it was like a very
bonding experience early on
um she's a writer and director and a
brilliant woman and uh I'm very lucky to
be with her yeah y'all are so cute so
just curious that's it yeah it's a long
time ago
still together if you're if you're y'all
are so cute so wait how did you get home
if it's total did y'all like her friend
came and picked us up oh okay okay it
was it was very nice but yeah then you
got to meet a friend he got right in
there I got right in there I hugged her
I phoned her after because texting
didn't exist yet yeah you called a human
I called a human yeah
um yeah and uh yeah and then we we
started dating and it was a beautiful uh
a beautiful thing
um on one of uh I don't know if I should
tell the story I'll just tell it you can
cut it if you want this story is gross
so on one of our earliest First Dates uh
I had just gotten back from Mexico where
I don't know if you've been but they
tell you don't drink the water and don't
eat fruits and vegetables I ate a lot of
salad when I was there don't ask me why
and I came back and we had one of our
first sleepovers at my place
and uh I was gonna walk her to her car
and I lived in like a second story walk
up and I and she lived and she parked
like a block away from me and uh and I
got dressed and I was ready to walk her
out and I was like literally remember
like looking at myself in the mirror and
she was like getting her keys and she's
like ready to go and I was like Seth
like my first ever long-term girlfriend
I'd ever had I was in my own apartment
she was there we just slept over I was
like this could be the beginning of a
beautiful thing and then my pants
horribly
like as bad as you fathomably could and
then I heard a knock on the door and
she's like ready let's go
and I was like I think I really love
this woman I can't I can't let her know
she parked one block away I have to walk
one entire block having just myself
and and I put my arm around her and I
walked her down the stairs and think she
didn't know it was a breezy day in L.A
thank God and I walked her to her car
and I I I I hugged her goodbye and I
remember her driving away you don't want
to walk after you yourself let me be
clear you on a freezing Place remove
everything if you can like you've been
in a chemical spill you don't wanna you
don't wanna move
I had made a journey you know and I
remember standing there on the street
just waving at her being like there goes
the love of my life I have I think I
have to burn these shoes yeah
tell her that story when I wrote the
book
around 15 years later it took a minute
it took 15 years for me to be like so
she won't break up with me
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]